[Music]
[Applause]
140.
[Music]
moderate traffic
we're going to be going left from
american front baseline
heading eastbound on american
just before starting the 31st street
i caught up to southeast 44th avenue
road there's moderate vehicle traffic
yeah i might be able to intercept here
we're south of southeast 41st or from
72nd street speeds are
80.
coming up to pine
northbound back on 441 heading back
towards the city
we're going to be eastbound on southeast
73rd street from 441
let me go here let me know if you get
41st
north south i'm going to be here with
six
could be down southeast 30th court road
on a dirt road take downtown
so going to the woods line now we're
going east line away from the
railroad track on the wood line
again it looks like he might be getting
ready to bail
street
all right
they're trying to get again
[Music]
foreign
all right
okay
3308
[Music]
all right we are eastbound
56th
[Music]
street me go let me know if you guys are
on my 44th
[Music]
grab